eu tô reporter que amo conta a história
e hoje eu vim contar pra vocês uma
história muito bonita é a história das
escolegis essa é andréia e andréia
sempre fez as malas dos filhos para
viagens com a avó
esses meninos sempre reclamaram mãe
esqueceu isso mãe colocou aquilo
sabe como é né andréia também insistia
ela existia mas esses meninos não
estudava até que um dia andréia fez um
curso de graça na internet e as coisas
começaram a mudar
andré se deu conta que ela estava se
preocupando demais com eles e de menos
com ela mesma e reequilibrou essa conta
passou a dar mais responsabilidade para
esses meninos a cuidar mais dela mesma
e hoje essa é andréia andré está 18
quilos mais magra mas o mais bonito não
é isso o mais bonito eu vi andréia dizer
que antes os meninos diziam amanhã chata
agora os meninos dizem ah mamãe é linda
e essa transformação se explica pelo
fato dela ser o colégio ficou a aluna da
escola de você chama uma das outras e
esse curso é para mulheres mas muitos
homens observando o que aconteceu com
suas esposas resolveram fazer também é o
caso do valquíria valkyrie percebeu que
a lúcia tava muito mais alegre e muito
mais parceira e decidiu fazer o curso
também então o walquir tomou a decisão
de fazer uma cirurgia que ele tinha
desistido há muito tempo ele tinha 40 58
anos e achava que já estava velho demais
para fazer a cirurgia de catarata apesar
de praticamente não enxergar mais depois
que valcke fez o curso e resolveu fazer
a cirurgia ele escreveu depois da
cirurgia para agradecer e foi a mensagem
mais linda que eu já recebi de um aluno
o valcke escreve
eu eu nasci de novo
engraçado né porque assim o que esse
curso faz tudo para nasceu de novo
a coisa mais simples do mundo
a gente só ajuda a pessoa a reencontrar
a sua própria natureza onde está o seu
maior valor
valquir ele reencontrou o amor próprio
que há muito estava perdida gente olha
como ele provou ambiental que pode mais
não volte com a deborah foi parecido
a deborah fez o curso que com animadora
resolveu resgatar o sonho de ser
dentista voltou para a faculdade de
odonto olha aí no laboratório de odonto
só que há três semanas a débora recebeu
o diagnóstico de câncer e foi para a
lona
a deborah já estava se preparando para o
pior
então ela estava pensando até em largar
a faculdade mas essa história também
mudou com a ação das amigas colegas que
invadiram a casa da débora essas
mulheres lembraram a débora que ela não
está sozinha
lembraram a débora que diante de uma
situação de vida ou morte é preciso
escolher viver e lembraram a débora que
quando a gente tem uma rede forte é bem
mais fácil escolher viver e eu poderia
gente ficar aqui horas contando
histórias porque essas mulheres as
alunas da escola de você
as coletas são minhas amigas e eu
orgulhosamente digo que eu tenho 112 mil
856 amigas e engraçado porque até muito
pouco tempo eu só fazia isso só
trabalhava na televisão fazer reportagem
apresentava jornal
eu chegava às casas de milhões de
pessoas
mas eu não tocava de verdade a vida de
ninguém entende
eu sempre quis tocar de verdade a vida
das mulheres do meu tempo porque o
estudo o comportamento feminino há
muitos anos é que a minha avó avó teté
ela foi retirada antes da seca ela
precisou se casar os 13 anos
idade para ter o que comer então o
desejo de fazer alguma coisa pelas
mulheres do meu tempo era gigante em mim
ea fórmula de sucesso nasceu do encontro
com essas grandes essas irmãs que eu
escolhi pra minha vida e mostraram que
juntos a gente faz muito mais do que
sozinho ea mágica que a gente faz nesse
curso de graça na internet
na soma de conteúdo útil colocado de um
jeito fácil de entender
tratando as pessoas com carinho e com
verdade a gente tem uma fundamentação
teórica enorme é a base da escola de
você tem sêneca vários toques eles
maslow ou que ajeitando os outros mas a
gente toca tão profundamente a gente
impacta de verdade as vidas das pessoas
porque a gente tenha coragem de ser
simples
a gente tem muito problema complicado né
todos nós ademais teoria para muita
gente não é eficaz porque é repetir o
pensamento dos grandes da humanidade não
é complicado a gente repete
difícil é trazer o conjunto do melhor
que a inteligência humana já produziu de
uma forma que responda à pergunta tá o
que eu faço com isso como é que eu
aplico isso na minha vida como é que eu
melhoro a minha vida com isso
está aí a mágica da escola de você
trazer de forma muito simples conteúdo
útil
a gente faz isso com vídeos divertidos
curtinhos que trazem sempre uma situação
do dia a dia a gente vai numa lógica de
melhoramento contínuo um passo de cada
vez
ensinando cada pessoa a cuidar primeiro
desse para só depois ter o seu melhor
para oferecer os outros então é assim a
gente traz uma encenação de uma situação
do dia a dia como por exemplo a
insegurança no relacionamento novo
ninguém nunca sentiu aqui a insegurança
no amor do ovo ou uma competição com
outra pessoa em outra
trabalho aí a pessoa se vê no vídeo mas
de um jeito leve
é mais ou menos assim hum cara eu sou a
mulher do vídeo eu me faço de vítima
para chantagear meu marido ou então
assim as não é que eu me sabotando o
tempo todo também e assim a gente vai
despertando o amor o amor por si mesmo
eo amor pela vida
as alunas da escola de você
assis coletes são pra mim a prova mais
inequívoca de que ativar o melhor ativar
as virtudes das pessoas funciona
dá muito mais resultado do que tentar
apontar e combater os vícios delas assis
collets ao ativar o seu melhor
elas conseguem sair dessa posição de
vítima ea luta apesar de todas as
dificuldades que todos nós temos mesmo e
dessa conexão consigo mesma desse
caminho que é individual ali eu e meu
computador eu e meu celular
nasce o desejo de se conectar
fisicamente de conhecer outras mulheres
que também estão nessa transformação a
partir delas a iniciativa de fazer
encontros por todo o brasil
então a nossa escola cresce nos dois
sentidos bom line e off line e off line
para online do digital para as ruas e
das ruas para o digital é a mulher que
está ali na mesa do lado na padaria onde
um grupo de colete está reunido que
houve aquela conversa animada e saber o
que faz aquelas mulheres ali tão felizes
entre agosto indica marca foto
compartilha o digital é muito poderoso
mas o nosso maior valor já aí está no
olho no olho tá na recomendação boca a
boca da manicure dentro do ônibus no
trabalho é tão grandioso que a gente
está construindo juntas que em menos de
um ano nós somos reconhecidos
internacionalmente como inovação
pedagógica duas vezes pelo simples que
funciona
a gente vive imerso num turbilhão de
informações concordam é tanta a imagem
som que a gente fica confuso e confusa
as pessoas erram elas eram muito o que a
escola de você faz é só ensinar um bom
senso
o bom senso que predispõem você a
entender o outro o bom senso que faz a
gente não tem preconceito o bom senso
que faz a gente não ficar fazendo um
plano de vingança
o bom senso que leva uma vida boa é só o
simples o simples que muitas vezes a
gente ignora e cada mulher que toma essa
consciência que passa a viver no seu
melhor
acaba virando ponte para que outras
mulheres entrem nessa rede que não pára
de crescer o que eu vim fazer aqui foi
compartilhar com vocês os pilares que
sustentam essa rede de auto conhecimento
e de progresso feminino 1
sabe aquele olhar que a gente tem
diante de uma criança que começa a dar
os primeiros passinhos
o babbo se as primeiras palavras é um
olhar de de abertura de aceitação
daquela nova vida não é sempre o
conceito sem julgamento
quando uma mulher consegue olhar pra
outra
desse jeito maravilhas acontecem
amizades negócios progresso competição
tem hora e tem lugar mas não pode ser a
base o fundamento das relações entre
mulheres aprovado que quem busca o que é
seu
mas em colaboração com pessoas que têm
os mesmos propósitos prospera muito mais
dois
a base das relações entre pessoas de bem
é o ganha ganha
se eu quero ganhar antes eu penso como é
que eu posso trazer algo de bom para as
pessoas que estão à minha volta é o que
os norte americanos chamam de games game
ou ganho de quem doa eu vejo todos os
dias as mulheres mais interessadas em
colaborar com as outras
são as que mais crescem
ponto número 3 todo mundo tem medo de
ser abandonado de errar de não ser amado
de que as coisas não dêem certo
o que separa as pessoas que conseguem
encontrar o seu melhor e viver em paz
nas pessoas que vivem frustrada e
apontando os erros das outras é a
habilidade de fazer o que precisa ser
feito apesar do medo é a máxima que os
empreendedores transformaram em bordão
que tá com medo vai comer do mesmo mas
vai quarto ponto
viver bem como andréia o walquir alucia
e a deborah tem feito é a melhor maneira
de deixar um legado e ensinar as
próximas gerações a fazer o mesmo
colocar a minha decisão de ser feliz no
centro de todas as minhas escolhas têm
um impacto gigantesco nos meus filhos
meus amigos na minha comunidade e
funciona muito melhor do que aquela
velha idéia de me sacrificar pelo outro
então o que a nossa escola ensina é que
é triste e é inútil passar o resto da
vida apontando culpados e defeitos
o que a gente ensina é que conhecer e
cultivar o amor e o bem dentro de si dá
muito resultado
a gente não precisa falar muito das
limitações que foram impostas a nós
mulheres ao longo dos séculos
eu acho que todo mundo entende aqui o
prejuízo dessa programação de ser apenas
um útero ou instrumento de prazer
detectar disponível 100 por cento de
tempo pra todo mundo de cuidar de todos
e muitas vezes abandonasse são essas
regras das outras pessoas que me fazem
ter e que se a imagem que eu vejo
refletida no espelho não parece com uma
top model então eu sou menos que ela
estou menos que a minha vizinha que a
minha amiga
o que a gente precisa fazer aos poucos
sem nenhum peso
cada uma no seu ritmo é devagarinho e
tirando essas camadas de valores que não
são meus porque a humanidade toda ganha
quando uma mulher consegue romper essas
molduras encontrar o seu jeito próprio
de viver
todo mundo ganha quando um indivíduo
seja ele homem ou mulher prospera se
realiza não seria muito legal se a sua
mãe sua irmã sua mulher sua filha
ganhasse 30% a mais ninguém ganha com a
desigualdade de gêneros
por isso eu acredito que nós mulheres
somos responsáveis por liberar uma
transformação uma transformação que
começa na forma de pensar e depois se
desdobra em comportamentos mas eu
acredito também que a gente só vai
conseguir alcançar o nosso objetivo se a
gente conseguir trazer os homens juntos
e eu acho que é possível é possível a
gente só precisa tirar todos nós homens
e mulheres do nosso repertório do nosso
discurso frases aparentemente ingênuas
que reduzem a mulher é ver é muito fácil
a fota fofoca coisa de mulher
ou então atrapalhando o trânsito só pode
ser mulher essa é a mulher está
dirigindo certeza ou então aí é uma
médica não tem médico não tem engenheiro
engenheiro não sei não gosto ou então
olha a roupa é simples a gente entrar
para a história como a geração que
fechou o abismo que construiu ao ponte
para a igualdade de gêneros
é um sonho gigante mas que tem uma saída
muito simples é só a gente começar agora
tirando essas frases e quando ficar
difícil a gente só precisa lembrar que
tudo o que a gente pensa que tudo que a
gente fala sobre mulheres
gravado nas nossas crianças desenha a
moldura na qual as nossas crianças vivem
e na prática constrói um mundo no qual
as filhas das nossas filhas e as filhas
delas vão viver
então meu convite para que cada um aqui
é que nós juntos possamos construir um
novo novo simples bom um mundo no qual
homens e mulheres sejam apenas humanos
humanos tão tão tão incrivelmente
diferentes em tantos aspectos mas iguais
na grandeza e na beleza de ser a criação
mais maravilhosa do universo
muito obrigada gente